est-ce que vous ne voyez pas le
capitalisme depuis sa naissance à la fin
du moyen-âge à la voie en italie et dans
les flandres comme une force
terriblement révolutionnaire au fond
c'est fou ce que le capitalisme a changé
il s'est dressé il a été le premier
pratiquement la première organisation à
se dresser contre l'arbitraire des
princes et contre le fanatisme des
prêtres c'est à partir du droit de la
propriété que s'est établie s'est
constitué l'état de droit sansan les
échanges marchands on n'aurait jamais
codifié tout ça en tout cas pas de la
même manière sans doute pas de la daube
et bien sûr il a été révolutionnaire le
cabinet et peut-être les t-il encore
d'ailleurs les tenants du capitaliste du
capitalisme se flatte d'avoir sorti plus
de 800 millions de personnes de
l'extrême pauvreté de mai j'ai compté
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
exact actuellement c'est tout à fait
exact et je pense que de ce point de vue
là dans un ensemble que je considère
qu'il faut construire comme façon
beaucoup plus vaste et c'est à dire
l'histoire néolithique de l'humanité
c'est-à-dire celle qui s'est constitué
il ya quatre ou cinq mille ans autour
d'eux justement à la propriété privée
l'agriculture sédentaires ou maman les
chasseurs cueilleurs nos ancêtres et la
saison tard il a sein du chasseur
cueilleur et et avec tout ça l'état
destinée à protéger justement
l'organisation de la société
on est entré dans une nouvelle période
de l'histoire d'humanité et il est hors
de doute que le capitalisme est le
couronnement l'achèvement probable de de
cet immense séquence ce qui donne aussi
une certaine amplitude à toute idée de
d'aller au-delà toute idée d'aller au
delà c'est quand même comme si on
proposait une sortie de cet édifice
néolithique qui quand même nous ad
animalisés qui fut dire café de
l'humanité l'appareil peut être
monstrueux qu'elle est sur cette planète
donc voila et capitalisme ça désigne ça
ça désigne la figure en effet à la fois
paroxystique à mon avis terminal d'une
séquence historique de plusieurs
millénaires
alors on peut toujours dire évidemment
que l état bien des égards supérieure à
tout ce qui a précédé
ça c'est un dû
table
[Musique]